und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend es
ist nicht bekannt wie die Niederländer
es fanden dass die Gäste aus Deutschland
schlaflos angereist waren große Freude
machen kann das eigentlich nicht
Gesprächspartnern gegenüber zu sitzen
die kaum noch die Augen aufhalten können
aber der Termin für die gemeinsame
deutsch-niederländische Kabinettssitzung
war halt langfristig vereinbart da
mussten sie jetzt heute alle durch wie
nützlich solche nächtlichen
marathon-sitzungen die bei diesem
Koalitionsausschuss sind darüber lässt
sich ja trefflich streiten sollte der
Plan gewesen sein den Publikum zu zeigen
wie gut man miteinander klarkommt ist
der allerdings nicht aufgegangen wer
nach fast 20 Stunden nur Augenringe aber
keine Ergebnisse präsentieren kann kommt
ja offenkundig nicht so gut miteinander
klar aus Berlin Britta Buchholz
als Berlin am Morgen erwacht haben
einige Spitzenpolitiker noch gar nicht
geschlafen bereits 12 Stunden dauern da
die Verhandlungen im Kanzleramt nichts
dringend nach außen zu den warten denn
die Gespräche laufen noch fünf weitere
Stunden als die übliche
regierungspressekonferenz beginnt
Ergebnisse auch hier keine dafür
atmosphärisches
als ich den Kanzler vorhin traf hatte
ich nicht den Eindruck dass er besonders
viel geschlafen hätte heute Nacht werden
die Ministerin überhaupt
sprechfähig sein wenn sie gerade 24
Stunden durchgearbeitet haben
ja
die marathon-sitzung wird zum Symbolbild
der Ampel offensichtlich liegen SPD
Grüne und FDP bei vielem sehr weit
auseinander das Auto bleibt dabei nur
ein Zankapfel der Koalition ein
Kernproblem wo grüne klare Vorgaben
wollen Glauben liberale nicht an
Regulierung nach fast 20 Stunden
schaltet die Ampel schließlich auf Rot
die Gespräche werden unterbrochen
offizieller Grund das halbe Kabinett
reist für den deutschen niederländischen
Regierungskonsultationen inoffiziell ist
klar der Kanzler konnte die streithemen
nicht abräumen nach der Landung versucht
er die Unterbrechung klein zu reden wir
haben in den Beratung sehr sehr gute
Fortschritte erzielt viele viele
Verständigung gewonnen und haben alles
dazu beigetragen dass wir die wichtigen
Festlegungen erarbeiten die für die
Modernisierung und den fort unseres
Landes und für den Fortschritt in
Deutschland notwendig sind
mehr Fortschritt Wagen das war das große
Ziel das Koalitionsvertrages für die
Ampel versprachen sie keine
durchstecherei ein für die Sondierungen
versprachen sie keine Nachtsitzung es
sollte anders werden als einst bei
Jamaika die Unterbrechung nun eine
Steilvorlage für die Opposition die
Ampel wollte für Fortschritt stehen viel
für Klimaschutz machen und keine
Nachtsitzung mehr wir erleben das exakt
die Gegenteil seit nunmehr Monaten gibt
es ein erbitterten Streit über alle
Fragen des Klimaschutzes des
Klimaschutzgesetz wird nicht eingehalten
ist Energieeffizienzgesetz wird
blockiert das ist natürlich ein
Armutszeugnis für diese Regierung die
sich ja nicht erst seit heute
zerlegt sondern ähm das läuft ja schon
mehrere Monate an dass dort in der Ampel
Regierung keine Einigkeit erzeugt werden
kann zum Zustand der Ampel gehört aber
auch das heute fast nichts nach außen
dringt Vertrauen in Zeiten von Krisen
Treffen morgen wird weiter verhandelt
ja von den direkt Beteiligten wollte
sich heute erwartungsgemäß natürlich
keiner äußern da ist dann auch eher
schweigen und schlafen das Gebot der
Stunde also analysieren wir die Lage mit
einem Politikwissenschaftler Karl Rudolf
Korte ist bei uns im Studio namens guten
Abend ja wir haben es gehört eigentlich
wollte diese Koalition ja diese
nächtlichen Sitzungen die es herunter
Merkel oft gegeben hat nicht mehr haben
aber es geht anscheinend nicht ohne ja
denn normalerweise zur Koordination eine
Regierung die mittwochs die
Kabinettssitzung da läuft es zusammen da
ist man abgestimmt jetzt hat man das auf
einer Partei Ebene gehoben durch den
Koalitionsausschuss zu 20 und nachts hat
man nicht nur Festspiele des Denkens da
ist man einfach auch mal müde und fragt
sich warum es sein muss aus Zeitgründen
vermutlich wenn man andere Termine sonst
nicht hinbekommt es hat ja auch sowas
architarisches ne so ein bisschen wer
geht zuerst k.o und wer hält durch ja
und aber andererseits ist Zeit ein
Codewort für Freiheit und wenn man sich
Zeit nimmt kann man auch zu anderen
Optionen kommen wer in dieser Situation
sich gedrängt und bedrängt fühlt wird
auch keine kreativen Lösungen finden das
weiß man aus verhandlungsmanagement und
sind ja 20 Stunden schon eine ganze
Menge Zeit wie interpretieren sie das
denn dass da dann heute aber kein
einziges also auch nicht ein Ergebnis
gezeigt werden konnte ja einmal dass wir
nicht wissen um was wirklich gerungen
wird ist ein gutes Zeichen das
vertrauensvoll offenbar noch man
zusammenarbeiten kann aber der Graben
ist so groß die Differenzen sind so
unterschiedlich dass man offenbar keinen
Ausweg im Moment erkennen kann ein
Ausweg wäre ja über eine
führungserzählung beispielsweise die der
Kanzlerin turniert Auswege zu finden um
die Dynamik des Miteinanders auf die man
sich am Anfang der Koalition verständigt
hat auch am Ende zu einigen man
Vertrauen scheint er dann inzwischen
auch zu viel und das war ja schon recht
heftig was habe ich da also den Raum
gestellt hat zu sagen das ist
durchgestochen worden damit ich blöd
aussehe das ist ja auch eine
Boshaftigkeit eigentlich die man dann da
dem Koalitionspartnern wäre auch immer
es gewesen sein soll unterstellt das
könnte man auch bislang nicht das war
doch so dass das interne auch intern
blieb und das war auch ein
leistungszeichen für die Zusammenarbeit
der Koalition aber man merkt dass nach
einem Jahr oder gut einem Jahr ein
Neustart offenbar ja notwendig ist das
weniger ist zu verteilen nicht zu
gewinnen und deswegen brauchen wir auch
einen neuen Mechanismus offenbar um auch
Zumutungen gemeinsam aussprechen zu
können denn das was wir nicht mehr haben
wollen als Bürger ist ja sich auf dem
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner zu einigen
das ist groko ideal gewesen wir wollen
ja Ergänzungen hören also kreative
Auswege und darauf können wir natürlich
noch hoffen wir wissen es aber nicht man
kann das funktionieren mit drei Parteien
diese unterschiedlich sind und die FDP
die da so ein bisschen mit dem Rücken an
der Wand steht und sich unbedingt
profilieren will und die Grünen die sich
so im Regen stehen gelassen fühlen von
Scholz das ist ja irgendwie keine
glückliche Konstellation im Moment zwei
eigentlich eher als drei und wir haben
das schwächste Mandat für einen Kanzler
den es je gab also mit 25%
und man muss immer sehen er ist in der
Minderheit gegenüber den zitruskoalition
grün und gelb denn dauerhafte Minderheit
heißt nicht dass er groß auf den Tisch
hauen kann wenn er das mal macht mit der
richtigen Kompetenz ist das sicherlich
eine Ausnahme man soll ja morgen
weiterverhandelt werden also da müssen
sie dann ja irgendwas präsentieren oder
sonst ging es ginge ja gar nicht anders
ohne was zu zeigen die Erwartungshaltung
ist hoch dass ein Ergebnis kommt dass
uns kreativ auch beflügelt also Auswege
und nicht Vertagung und auch nicht nur
dass man sieht wer jetzt welche Pakete
bekommen hat also eine Kultur der
Differenz sondern gemeinsames als Ausweg
und das geht wahrscheinlich durchaus
durch den Weg und Bürgern Zumutung
zuzumuten die alle drei Parteien aber
treffen
danke für die Analyse
letztendlich sind die Streitigkeiten in
unserer Koalition hierzulande natürlich
normale demokratische Vorgänge würden
alle immer das Gleiche wollen bräuchte
man ja auch keine unterschiedlichen
Parteien was hingegen eine echte
Regierungskrise ist mehr noch eine
veritable Staatskrise das sieht man
gerade in Israel Benjamin netanjaro und
seine in Teilen extremistischen
Koalitionspartner versuchen Israel zu
einem autokratischen Regierungssystem um
zu formen in dem rechtsstaatliche
Grundprinzipien nicht mehr gelten sollen
da haben sie allerdings die Rechnung
ohne die Bevölkerung gemacht solche
Massendemonstrationen wie hier letzte
Nacht hat das Land noch nicht erlebt es
sind nicht mehr nur einfach Proteste es
ist ein Aufstand Michael Beverungen
berichtet aus Israel
und wieder sind Zehntausende auf den
Straßen in Tel Aviv Jerusalem und dem
ganzen Land der Rückhalt in der
Gesellschaft ist groß viele unterstützen
die Demonstrierenden spontan mit etwas
zu essen so wie Papier sie ist sogar
ganz offiziell mit dem Segen ihrer
Hightech-Firma unterwegs
heute hatten wir einen Empfang aber wir
haben entschieden unsere Tablets hierher
zu bringen und die Sachen bei der Demo
zu verteilen und mit zu demonstrieren
den ganzen Tag übergibt es Gerüchte
Premiere tanjao wolle seine Justizreform
aussetzen die meisten sind davon
unbeeindruckt
wir demonstrieren schon lange nicht mehr
nur gegen die neuen Gesetze wir wollen
dass die gesamte wahnsinnige Regierung
ihrer Arbeit niederlegt diesen Wahnsinn
zu Ende bringt damit das Volk wieder
eins wird es geht schon lange nicht mehr
nur um die Reform
netanjaro hatte gestern den
Verteidigungsminister entlassen und
stand selbst vor einer Regierungskrise
der Verlust der Mehrheit drohte galant
und weitere Liquid Mitglieder hatten
einen Stopp der Reform gefordert
umgekehrt rote für diesen Fall der
rechtsextreme Minister Benk wir mit
Rücktritt erst nach zehn Verhandlungen
verkündete Tanja auch am Abend die
Gesetzgebung wird ausgesetzt achso
es darf keinen Bürgerkrieg geben wir
befinden uns auf dem Wege eines
gefährlichen Zusammenstoßes in der
israelischen Gesellschaft wir sind
mitten in einer Krise welche die Basis
unserer Einheit gefährdet doch sie sind
ob die Gegner Netanjahus Worten Glauben
schenken darf bezweifelt werden zu tief
ist der rissen der Gesellschaft der
Oppositionsführer kündigt dagegen an
Gespräche ohne Vorbedingungen zu
akzeptieren wir sind bereit zu
Gesprächen zusammen mit dem
Staatspräsidenten der Staat Israel ist
verletzt und leidet da kann man nicht
einfach ein Pflaster auf die Wunde
kleben sondern wir müssen uns wirklich
darum kümmern zum 75 geburtstag des
Landes müssen wir eine Verfassung
Schreiben auf einer Demonstration
10.000er Anhänger der Regierung in
Jerusalem stellt Ben gewirkt klar was er
von solchen Gesprächen hält
ich habe so gedacht und ich denke immer
noch so man darf gegenüber Anarchisten
nicht kapitulieren
auch in Tel Aviv dauert der Protest der
Regierungsgegner am Abend an ist der
Graben zur anderen Seite überwindbar der
Generalstreik der Gewerkschaften wurde
inzwischen wieder abgesagt ein Ende des
verfassungskonflikts ist nicht absehbar
nur eine kurze Pause um Atem zu holen
dann schalten wir noch Tel Aviv zu
unserem Korrespondenten Michael
Beverungen Michael dass diese
Justizreform jetzt nur verschoben wird
dass das wird den Kritikern ja nicht
reichen das löst ja nicht oder
ich glaube nicht nur den Kritikern
sondern auch den Befürwortern dieser
Reform denn die haben heute auch noch
mal unterstrichen dass sie auf gar
keinen Fall von den Zielen der Reform
fest abweichen wollen und wie da eine
Einigung aussehen soll ist
schlechterdings vorzustellen denn wie
soll es ein bisschen Gewaltenteilung
geben ich glaube Netanya wollte heute
mit diesem Schritt Zeit gewinnen ob
diese Zeit ausreichen wird um eine
Lösung tatsächlich herbeizuführen dazu
ist der Riss der durch die Gesellschaft
auch in vielen anderen Fragen geht
wahrscheinlich zu groß das war ja letzte
Nacht wirklich an eine besondere Nacht
wie ist denn jetzt dann Moment am Abend
so die Lage sind ähnlich viele wieder
auf der Straße ist die Situation immer
noch so aufgeheizt
ja also wirklich beruhigt ist die Lage
nicht hier in Tel Aviv gehen die
Demonstrationen immer noch weiter es hat
Verhaftung gegeben es könnte zu weiteren
Blockaden kommen wie gestern Nacht hier
auf der Stadt Autobahn dann wird wieder
geräumt möglicherweise mit Wasser werfen
also eine unmittelbar beruhigende
Wirkung dieser Scheinlösung die hat sich
noch nicht eingestellt danke schön für
die Einschätzung Michael
lange wurde über sie diskutiert nun sind
sie da die deutschen Panzer in der
Ukraine damit bei mir die Nachrichten
von Heinz Wolf ja die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte haben aus Deutschland 18
moderne Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer für die
Abwehr des russischen Angriffs auf ihr
Land erhalten das bestätigt die
Bundeskanzler Scholz während des Besuchs
in Rotterdam wir haben geliefert wie
angekündigt sagte Scholz
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
in der Stadt saporicia mit dem Chef der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde
grossi über die Situation am
nahegelegenen Atomkraftwerk saporisier
gesprochen das unter russischer
Kontrolle ist große sprach von einer
nach wie vor angespannten Lage dort das
AKW liegt in Front Nähe und so gibt es
Befürchtungen es könnte durch die
Gefechte zu einem Atomunfall kommen
das ungarische Parlament hat mit großer
Mehrheit für den Beitritt Finnlands zur
NATO gestimmt damit steht jetzt nur noch
die Ratifizierung der Türkei aus die
aber bereits angekündigt hat grünes
Licht geben zu wollen anders die
Situation für Schweden das gemeinsam mit
Finnland in die NATO wollte hier fehlt
noch die Zustimmung der Türkei und auch
die Ratifizierung durch Ungarn
trotz der großen Gefahren machen sich
weiter viele Migranten Verbot über das
Mittelmeer auf den Weg nach Europa
allein in der vergangenen Nacht waren es
650 Männer die in Italien ankamen und
vergangenen Wochenende erreichten laut
italienische Regierung knapp 5.600
Menschen die Küste im Süden des Landes
seit Jahresbeginn wurden bereits knapp
27.000 bootsmigranten registriert das
sind viermal mehr als im gleichen
Zeitraum vergangenes Jahr
an einer Grundschule in der Schwelle im
US-Bundesstaat Tennessee sind drei
Kinder und drei Erwachsene durch Schüsse
getötet worden mutmaßlich von einer
28-jährigen ehemaligen Schülerin die mit
mehreren Waffen über einen Seiteneingang
in die Schule gelangt war sie wurde von
Polizisten erschossen
US-Präsident beiden äußerte sich am
Abend zu der Tat erforderte erneut eine
Verschärfung des Waffenrechts mit einem
Verbot bestimmter Waffen
in Schottland wird er bisherige
Gesundheitsminister hansaiush neuer
Ministerpräsident und Vorsitzender der
Regierungspartei SNP der 37-Jährige
setzte sich in einer innerparteilichen
Abstimmung gegen zwei Mitbewerberinnen
durch yousaf tritt die Nachfolge von
Nicolas Deutschland
ihren Rückzug von allen Ämtern bekannt
gegeben hatte
es war zwar ein großer Streiktag heute
aber das von manchen befürchtete ganz
große Chaos blieb aus offenkundig
blieben viele Menschen zu Hause das mit
dem Homeoffice ist ja inzwischen
eingeübt vielen Reisenden wurden die
Pläne durchkreuzt die Härten die damit
einhergehen können machen sich aber
öffentlich wenig bemerkbar abgesagte
Termine und Reisen sieht man ja nicht im
Straßenbild auf den Straßen links
weitgehend normal zu Susanna berichtet
Stillstand heute den ganzen Tag auf
vielen deutschen Bahnhöfen wie hier in
Frankfurt am Main ähnlich saß an den
großen deutschen Flughäfen aus in
Frankfurt waren rund 1.200 staatsgeplant
fast alle Flüge vielen aus und wer nicht
rechtzeitig vor Streik Beginn einen
Anschluss bekam hing erstmal fest das
verständnisbedingt
quasi zum generalstreit Macht über ganz
Deutschland finde ich nicht
verhältnismäßig
verstehen für die Leute uns zu wenig
Geld haben
umdisponieren mussten heute viele dein
Wiesbaden auch alle Bus in ihren Depots
blieben hatten Sebastian selina hatte
und sein Sohn Ramon die Idee am Morgen
gemeinsam mit anderen Schülern mit dem
Fahrrad zur Schule zu fahren doch es kam
keiner die beiden fuhren alleine los
vor der Schule zeigte sich ein Grund
dafür sogenannte elterntaxis hatten
heute in vielen Städten Hochkonjunktur
schade findet dass Sebastian sellinat
mit den Streikenden erklärt er sich
solidarisch ich habe vollstes
Verständnis dass die Menschen für mehr
Geld auf die Straße gehen denn die
Inflation ist nun mal für alle da so
argumentieren auch wer die und die EVG
die mit geballter gewerkschaftsmacht
heute streiten Verdi mitten in der
dritten Verhandlungsrunde das sei
notwendig sagen viele Beschäftigte und
bitten um Verständnis
weil die Wertschätzung unserer
Tätigkeiten meiner Kollegen und auf
meiner nicht mehr der entspricht was die
kosten auch mittlerweile verursachen wir
als junge Menschen wollen natürlich auch
irgendwo attraktive Arbeitgeber haben
und bei den Zeiten die Arbeitszeiten die
wir haben Vergütung ist es auch sehr
schwierig da junge Menschen ranzukommen
bisher liegen die Tarifparteien weit
auseinander wer die fordert 10,5% mehr
mindestens 500 € im Monat die EVG will
12% mehr und mindestens ein Plus von 650
€. wir brauchen um an den Tisch zu
kommen ein verhandlungsfähiges Angebot
um in der Tarif Auseinandersetzung dann
wirklich konstruktiv am Tisch sitzen zu
können und auch zu einem Ergebnis kommen
zu können ein Plus von fünf Prozent
bietet die Arbeitgeberseite und betont
dass es kaum Spielraum gäbe wir müssen
neue Mitarbeiter einstellen für viele
neue Aufgabe und wir müssen denjenigen
die wir jetzt haben noch ich sag doch
mal so eine Aufstockung geben und das
alles zusammenzubringen wird kein
leichtes Unterfangen zum Leidwesen von
Millionen Menschen die heute in
irgendeiner Weise vom Streit betroffen
waren auf den Straßen blieb das
befürchtete Chaos aus viele konnten wohl
im Homeoffice arbeiten oder einen freien
Tag nehmen drei Tage wollen sie in
Potsdam nun verhandeln nach einer
Einigung sieht es nach dem heutigen Tag
nicht aus
ja während die einen für mehr Lohn
kämpfen müssen andere befürchten dass es
ihren Job bald nicht mehr gibt durch die
neuen Schließungen bei Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof werden mehrere tausend ihre
Stellen verlieren für immerhin 12.000
gibt es aber noch Hoffnung die Gläubiger
der insolventen Warenhauskette machten
heute den Weg frei für einen neuen
Sanierungsversuch
Frank Wittmann was was wurde denn da im
Wesentlichen beschlossen ja dass die
Gläubiger zwar Zähneknirschen ja sagen
damit aber auf einen Großteil ihres
Geldes verzichten insgesamt war heute
die Rede davon dass die Gläubiger mehr
als 1,3 Milliarden Euro nicht mehr
wiedersehen werden also wir sprechen von
Lieferanten und Vermietern vor allem
aber ist der Staat wenn wir über Geld
reden der der am meisten verliert er
hatte Galeria zuletzt ja noch mal mit
680 Millionen Euro unter die Arme
gegriffen nimmt man beide Insolvenzen
zusammen von mehr als zwei Jahren stand
die Kette ja schon mal vor dem Aus da
muss der Staat und damit der
Steuerzahler noch sehr viel mehr
abschreiben Handelsexperten sprechen von
fast einer Milliarde Euro an
öffentlichen Geldern der Großteil davon
sei weg aber eine wirkliche Alternative
gab es nicht denn die nicht Annahme des
Sanierungsplan des heute hätte die
unmittelbare Einstellung des
Geschäftsbetriebes bedeutet dann hätte
man alle Warenhäuser dicht gemacht nicht
nur diese voraus nicht jetzt 47 der
insgesamt 129 ja es wird ja das ganze
wird sich quasi verkleinert verschlankt
was wird denn in Wirtschaftskreisen
gesagt wie nachhaltig ist dieser
Insolvenzplan wird der springen es kommt
natürlich immer drauf an wie man fragt
aber die Sanierer sind optimistisch
viele aber hägen Zweifel schon in der
Vergangenheit hätte man immer gesagt die
Einschnitte sei notwendig damit der Rest
überleben könne funktioniert haben diese
Konzepte bislang nicht und so gab es
denn heute auch Stimmen die mit Blick
auf das traditionswarenhaus vom Tod auf
Raten Sprachen
danke für die Einordnung
der Bevollmächtigte für die Sanierung
zeigte sich heute aber zuversichtlicher
er sagte der Insolvenzplan gäbe Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof beste Chancen für eine
Rückkehr in die Erfolgsspur fragt sich
nur wo die Erfolgsspur ist wenn jemand
zurückkehren kann die Entwicklung der
letzten 10 20 Jahre spricht ja
tatsächlich eher dafür neue Pfade zu
beschreiben an einigen Standorten wurde
das schon gemacht notgedrungen nach der
Schließung das Warenhauses musste man
sich für die Gebäude etwas anderes
einfallen lassen Beispiel Herne dort
beginnt Thaddäus Parade seinen Bericht
nur die historische Fassade des
ehemaligen karstadthauses im Herzen der
Herner City ist geblieben dahinter alles
neu in der unteren Etage Gastronomie
Einzelhandel und ein Fitnesscenter
darüber Büros dort wo einst Rolltreppen
standen öffnen sich nun großzügige
Lichthöfe über Jahrzehnte war Karstadt
der Publikumsmagnet für Herne doch ab
2009 Geschichte mit jahrelangem
Leerstand also das tat richtig weh weil
wir dann zunächst mit
Eigentumsverhältnissen zu tun hatten die
unklar waren dann kamen die Fonds die im
Ausland ihren Sitz hatten dann kam erste
private Investoren die aber richtig
zielführend in die Idee nicht hatten bis
wir gesagt haben jetzt nehmen wir das
Heft des Handeln selbst in die Hand aber
kaufen nicht nur die Immobilie mit einer
städtischen Tochter sondern entwickeln
einen Plan drumherum was passiert mit
Kaufhaus Filialen wenn Sie demnächst zu
sind auch sieben stand bereits zweimal
vor diesem Problem hier machte der
Kaufhof 2007 heute ist dort unter
anderem die Stadtbibliothek
untergebracht auch die Karstadt Filiale
im Stadtzentrum wird in Teilen anders
genutzt die Universität ist mit Hörsälen
und Seminarräumen in die obere Etage
eingezogen sollte Karstadt nun komplett
schließen werde man auch für die unteren
Etagen eine Lösung finden sagt der
Bürgermeister das Wichtige ist in diesem
Falle wir haben hier Siegener Investoren
das heißt der Eigentümer sitzt hier in
Siegen und das ist für viele der anderen
Kaufhäuser die jetzt im Moment auf der
Liste stehen das große Problem das sind
die Investoren in London oder in
Amsterdam und mit den kommt man schlecht
ins Gespräch möglichst schnell
miteinander ins Gespräch kommen daran
arbeiten Sie hier am Kölner Institut für
Handelsforschung unter ihrer
Federführung ist leeren entstanden eine
Plattform mit deren Hilfe eine Kommune
Nutzer und Anbieter an einem digitalen
Tisch zusammenführt
wir haben mit Lehrern eine digitale
Leerstand zum
ansiedlungsmanagement-plattform
geschaffen mit der Kommunen in die Lage
versetzt werden zu gestalten und
gestalten ist ein ganz wichtiger
Stichpunkt wenn man sagen Innenstädte
sind im Strukturwandel und die müssen
neu werden müssen anders werden das
heißt es ist sowas wie ein tinder für
Immobilien Flächen und Anbieter werden
einfach unbequem zusammengebracht und
die Standorte werden
zielgruppenspezifisch gestaltet das Aus
für viele kaufhausimmobilien es könnte
der Auftakt sein für eine Renaissance
der Innenstädte in Hamburg hat der
Abriss bereits begonnen statt
Parkhäusern und öden Verkaufsflächen
neue Wohn- und lebensquartiere Aufbruch
und Abschied zugleich nicht nur vom
Kaufhaus sondern auch vom Denken und
Anspruch einer ganzen Epoche
ist jetzt auch erst noch mal mit einem
Wirtschaftsthema weiter ja die Stimmung
in der deutschen Wirtschaft hat sich
laut dem ifo Geschäftsklimaindex im März
verbessert es ist der fünfte Anstieg des
konjunkturbarometers in Folge die etwa
9000 befragten Unternehmen aus
verschiedenen Branchen bewerteten ihre
aktuelle Geschäftslage überwiegend
besser und auch in die Zukunft wird mit
gestiegenen Erwartungen geschaut
rund ein halbes Jahr nach dem
Fischsterben in der oder wird weiter
nach den genauen Ursachen geforscht
heute gab es eine deutsch-polnische oder
Konferenz
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke will mit
einer Reihe von Maßnahmen einen besseren
Schutz erreichen dazu gehört laut Lemke
auch der Vorschlag ein
grenzüberschreitendes Frühwarnsystem zu
erarbeiten mit dem unter anderem die
Temperatur der oder kontinuierlich
überwacht wird
und noch zum Fußball die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft spielt nach dem 2:0
gegen Peru morgen gegen Belgien und zwar
in Köln vor der Abfahrt dorthin gab es
heute noch mal Informationen zur
Mannschaft und ein Training am DFB
Campus in Frankfurt am Main
mehr Licht als Schatten beim Training
der DFB-Elf in Frankfurt sinnbildlich
für die aktuelle Stimmung Samstag der
Sieg gegen Peru im neuen System mit
Füllkrug ein neuer Führungsspieler der
Hoffnung weckt auf bessere
Chancenverwertung in der Zukunft kann
sie fliegt zufrieden auch wenn mit
Schlotterbeck und Herbert zwei wichtige
stützenausfallen es muss und wird weiter
getestet werden
also so dass das natürlich für Kai und
für Nico Thilo Kehrer wird wird in der
Innenverteidigung spielen und sehr
Spinnen kaufen sehr knapp wird auf dem
Kaiser der Position spielen
Belastungsprobe für gnabry und kehre und
das gesamte DFB-Team gegen eine
belgische Mannschaft mit einem alten
bekannten deutschen traue ich alles zu
weil ja junge Gesichter schon aber ja
ist einfach eine Top Nation mit Top
Spiele noch gehts zu arbeiten an den
großen und kleinen Dingen beim DFB um
die dunklen Wolken vollständig zu
vertreiben
das war's von uns vielleicht nach dem
Wetter geht es mit dem montagskino
weiter um 0:35 Uhr gibt es dann unsere
heute schon ein Update mit Christopher
Wehrmann auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend hier haben wir den Schnee
für Sie mal rosa eingefärbt und sie
sehen hier ein kleines schneefallgebiet
das weiter nach Südosten zieht dann aber
übernimmt schnell das hoch liliosa das
bis morgen Abend bereits Österreich
erreicht haben wird dann wird es von
dessen wieder wolkiger milder und dann
kommt auch wieder Regen heran jetzt aber
kommt erstmal dieses kleine schneetief
das nach Osten abzieht und Sie sehen
dass es vor allen Dingen in den
Mittelgebirgen unterm Alpenrand heute
Nacht schneien kann morgen über Tag
kommt dann das neue hoch vertreibt
Schnee und Schnee Regen immer mehr nach
Osten heute Nacht also machen sie sich
auf Temperaturen von 0 bis -5 Grad
gefasst plus fünf Grad sind es dagegen
an der Nordsee das liegt dort auch am
auflandigen Wind von der Nordsee es gibt
also noch weitere Schneeregen und
Schneeschauer vielleicht ist auch mal
Blitz und Donner dabei und es wird
rutschig denn fünf bis zehn Zentimeter
Neuschnee sind durchaus in die
Mittelgebirgen oder am Alpenrand zu
morgen Vormittag kann es dann noch
einige Schneeregen und Schneeschauer
zwischen der Elbmündung und der Donau
geben sonnig wird es an der Ostsee auch
im Westen zeigt sich häufiger die Sonne
nachmittags werden dort die Wolken
dichter und die Temperaturen liegen
zwischen vier Grad in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und 11 Grad am Oberrhein
der Mittwoch wird dann noch recht
freundlich und vor allen Dingen schon
wieder deutlich milder beacht bis 18
Grad Donnerstag und Freitag sind dann
wieder sehr wechselhafte Tage es bleibt
allerdings Bild ich wünsche dir noch
einen schönen Abend